[Musique]
je vous remercie de m'accueillir qui a
déjà entendu quelqu'un lui dire qu'il
était bon à rien pouvait lever la main
moi ça m'est arrivé voilà
eh bien ça prouve que dans notre monde
il ya des gens qui sont vraiment mal
intentionnés vous êtes bons à rien vous
êtes mauvais en tout et toute façon vous
arriverez jamais rien dans la vie c'est
dur non pour un être humain plus
particulièrement viré pour un enfant un
enfant qui peut être et mal dans sa peau
manque d'assurance est un peu timide a
du mal à trouver sa place
et puis il arrive que cet enfant ou sept
adultes 1 d'ailleurs n'arrive tellement
pas à trouver sa place que la seule
solution pour lui c'est de se dire voilà
je veux en finir
c'est dommage c'est extrêmement violent
le résultat en fait de ces mots c'est
une perte de confiance
le sentiment d'être inutile le repli sur
soi même et comme je vous le disais bien
voilà les gens qui se sentent plus
capable d'avancer bien se disent je veux
en finir
parce que cet engrenage en fait négatifs
qu'on leur a mis devant mener très très
tôt et bien ne trouve pas de solution
alors je voudrais dire que nous portons
tous la responsabilité des maux que nous
prononçons car même en face de l'échec
c'est très simple de dire mais c'est pas
grave t'inquiète pas on va recommencer
tu verras tu vas réussir ça va aller
mieux c'est quand même plus sympa ça non
vous trouvez pas que ce top 10 est de
toutes les sciences que l'homme peut et
doit savoir la principale c'est la
science de vivre de la manière à faire
le moins de mal et le plus de bien
possible accompagné considérer donner
envie très positif
à voir le sourire parfois c'est dur pour
moi je mangeais que deux neurones
je peux pas tout faire en même temps
mais vous voyez bien que ça c'est bien
plus positif et bien plus bénéfique à
l'être humain que d'entendre des mots
négatifs
je vais vous parler maintenant d'une
personne qui va illustrer ce propos elle
est née en 1965
cette femme en fait a subi une majeure
partie de sa scolarité
tout simplement parce que sa maîtresse
d'école la définit comme une cancres
elle avait mis au fond à droite de la
salle de la classe parce que c'était
l'endroit qu'elle réservait au moins
intelligent
cette femme à l'âge de 11 ans a commencé
à faire des ménages pour pouvoir gagner
un peu d'argent de poche
et puis elles adorent et l'écriture et
elle dort et la lecture alors plus tard
et bien là réussi à faire des études
littéraires et puis plus tard aussi aidé
en parallèle de sa vie professionnelle
et bien cette dame a commencé une vie
d'écrivaine a commencé à écrire le livre
une vie familiale difficile
un mariage raté un enfant à élever seule
la maladie un licenciement tous allons
pousser dans une profonde dépression
et encore une fois jusqu'à envisager le
suicide ce que l'on aurait pu faire
d'ailleurs parce que dans le fond ça
aurait peut-être déranger personne si ce
n'est son propre entourage
mais non elle a relevé les bras et parti
a dit non je vais réaliser mes rêves
elle a fait preuve de courage et
d'abnégation parce qu'elle voulait
réaliser ses rêves
en 1995 elle envoie trois tome de son
ouvrage à des maisons d'édition 12 à
refuse 2a refuse c'est énorme
aujourd'hui en 2018
elle a vendu plus de 500 millions de
livres et c'est certainement l'écrivaine
la plus prolifique des trente dernières
années
est ce que vous savez de qui on parle si
vous avez une idée
absolument absolument john rawlings
rendez compte un petit peu le chemin
parcouru
c'est incroyable incroyable et puis
thomas edison
thomas edison c'est vrai que c'est assez
vieux pour le coup thomas edison lui a
été congédié deux fois d'une entreprise
pas de deux entreprises et il a été
considéré comme trop stupides pour
apprendre quoi que ce soit c'est drôle à
vous il ya juste créer une ampoule
contemporaine
c'est grâce à lui qu'on voit clair en
fait et cette enfance cette invention en
fête fut le résultat d'un acharnement
venu à bout de plus de 1000 tentatives
infructueuses
voilà la prochaine fois que vous
entendrez quelqu'un qui vous dira que
vous êtes bon à rien et c'est pas grave
attaque y est je vais me débrouiller
voir ok moi quand j'étais adolescent
j'avais 12 ans j'ai commencé à
travailler très tôt pour proposer un
apprentissage de cuisinier et là j'ai eu
un professeur j'étais petit comme ça m'a
dit tellement à rien vous arriverez
jamais rien dans la vie et là il y avait
tous mes camarades qui me regardait avec
mépris et j'avais pu en mettre
je me disais en fait la meilleure
solution pour moi ce serait disparaître
vivent une situation familiale difficile
j'avais vraiment pas besoin de ça puis
bien j'étais dans le cas du petit garçon
dont je vous parlais tout à l'heure
mal dans sa peau est un peu timide
voilà je ne savais pas très bien en fait
comment me positionner et du coup je
perdais confiance en moi et même mon
maître d'apprentissage me disais mais
qu'est ce qu'on va bien pouvoir faire de
toi donc ce sont des années qui ont été
très dur à vivre
ceci dit j'ai quand même réussi je suis
devenu cuisinier parce que j'avais envie
d'être cuisinier donc j'ai réussi je ne
suis pas laissé abattre après tout ça
paraît pas grand chose mais ensuite je
suis devenu chef de cuisine
c'était un peu mieux chef de cuisine et
bien j'ai eu la chance de voyager dans
toute l'europe grâce à ce métier métier
fantastique qui m'a appris à faire plein
de choses
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui je fais un très
bon repas
et puis après j'ai eu un autre rêve il
ya des gendarmes des militaires des
pompiers peut-être dans la salle voilà
eh bien écoutez de tabor avant tout je
vais faire une petite dédicace aux
forces de l'ordre en général
vous savez que on en pense qu'on veut un
mais quelqu'un qui fait partie des
forces de l'ordre le matin quand il part
il met sa vie sur la table à disposition
de la population à disposition de ses
concitoyens et quand ils rentrent le
soir si elle est encore là il la
récupère il y en a beaucoup qui n'ont
pas récupéré alors que je faisais mon
service militaire
un de mes instructeurs gravats une autre
phrase dans ma vie et lui hausse est un
ancien c'est un ancien légionnaire alors
il fait un peu psy quoi il aimait bien
nous faire crier au rassemblement et
puis son cri favori s'était il suffit de
vouloir alors prié ça s'était jamais
assez fort mais en fin de compte cette
phrase a fait comme un contrepoids par
rapport à la première qui m'avait été
lancée lorsque j'étais plus petit et du
coup c'est devenu mon leitmotiv en fait
je me dis tout simplement quand je me
sens pas capable de faire quelque chose
c'est comme ce que je suis en train de
faire il suffit de vouloir en fait tout
simplement
heureusement la vie est bien faite parce
que si on rencontre des personnes
néfastes on rencontre aussi des très
bien et j'en ai rencontré beaucoup de
très bien qui m'ont permis d'évoluer qui
vont aider à avancer et qui m'ont aussi
fait prendre conscience que je pouvais
avoir des capacités de faire des choses
et donc serait de devenir gendarme
quand j'ai dit ça mon épouse elle m'a
dit tu te rappelles de ce que tu viens
de me dire là tu laisses ta vie sur la
table et non non tu vas faire autre
chose et puis moi j'avais vraiment envie
de le faire donc j'ai passé les concours
je fais tout ce qu'il fallait et j'ai
réussi je suis entre en école et je suis
devenu gendarme
et puis arrivé à paris on me propose
d'intégrer une section spéciale
d'observateurs qu'entre tireur en fait
ce sont des militaires qui sont destinés
à des tireurs d'élite qui travaille dans
une section de 21 personnels hommes et
femmes
des hommes est destiné à la protection
du président j'ai eu la chance de
protéger trois présidents français et
puis presque tous les présidents du
monde en fait envie en visite sur le
territoire
c'est une expérience encore une fois
inespéré est fantastique quand vous
partez du moment à rien a assuré la
protection du président c'est quelque
chose de génial je vivrai certainement
plus ce genre d'émotions quoique c'est
pas encore fini nous avons tous des
talents certains d'entre nous les
découvre très tôt dans leur vie et ils
réussissent tout en fait on a
l'impression qu'ils ont fait tout ce
qu'ils font et réussissent c'est
énervant et puis d'autres et bien
mettront un petit peu plus de temps
en tout cas une chose est sûre c'est que
nous avons tous du talent alors je vais
citer un autre philosophe qui est un
homme qui pour moi était très avisés
qu'ils n'étaient pas plus connu que
autour de son quartier mais qui disait
toujours tu sais florent
pour moi il faut vivre de la façon la
plus heureuse et c'est de réfléchir à
tout ça et puis je me suis rendu compte
qu'en fait pour moi la façon de revivre
la plus heureuse et bien c'était de
réaliser mes rêves je n'ai pas peur des
challenges shiv et j'avance je fonce
mais réaliser mes rêves bien entendu je
savais et j'avais compris que celui qui
interdirait de réaliser mes rêves
en fin de compte n'était autre que moi
donc j'ai fait tomber les barrières
j'ai pris les choses en main sans jamais
rien lâcher et c'est comme ça donc du
coup que je suis devenu cuisinier chef
de cuisine tireurs d'élite à gendarmerie
j'imagine que vous avez desriveaux si
vous vous rappelez de vos rêves
d'enfants ont toutes été possible
rien ne pouvez vous arrêter je me
rappelle je voulais être indiana jones
vous étiez vous est peut-être être
astronaute sat mathématicien non pas
mathématique physiciens se présente on
avait tous des rêves
j'imagine que vous en avez réalisé
certains et peut-être que certains
d'entre vous ont fait de leur rêve une
réalité et de leur vie un rêve aussi eh
bien personne ne peut vous interdire de
rêver personne
le rêve c'est personnel ces voix là j'ai
des rêves je réalise et alors tout va
bien tout va bien aujourd'hui comment
est ce que je pense demain puisque c'est
intéressant aussi ça qui qui nous
intéresse comment est ce qu'on pense de
main alors mon parcours à fait que je
suis revenue depuis quatre ans dans la
restauration et du coup je me suis posé
un certain nombre de questions sur ce
que je pourrais apporter et rendre un
petit peu ce que la société m'a donné et
bien pouvoir le rendre et donc
j'envisage de créer une entreprise c'est
un projet sur lequel je suis en train de
travailler qui va j'espère voir le jour
très rapidement qui a qui a pour
objectif de permettre à la plus grande
partie de la population de bénéficier
d'une meilleure alimentation en
fabriquant du pain bio
permettez-moi 100% origine france pour
la restauration collective et donc là je
parle d'un du scolaire notamment de
l'entreprise mais aussi du social et du
médico social voilà cette entreprise en
fait elle va me permettre de réaliser
plusieurs rêves
c'est le rêve tout d'abord de créer
quelque chose de mes propres mains et de
pouvoir vivre de cette création
ça c'est quand même chose de fabuleux ce
que je n'ai jamais fait quelque chose
que je veux faire depuis très longtemps
deuxièmement participer à la vie
économique locale
troisièmement permettre à des gens que
je connais peut-être autour de moi de
trouver du travail dans un village où
malheureusement n'y en a pas beaucoup et
puis plutôt que laisser une empreinte
carbone et bien laissé une empreinte
positive avoir des rêves c'est bien
cela dit tout à l'heure ce qu'il faut
aussi c'est que on puisse mettre les
moyens pour réaliser ses rêves
et donc j'ai l'habitude de dire que je
ne suis jamais allé au tant à l'école
que depuis que j'y vais plus l'école
mais pas moi non plus mais en fait je
fais que ça j'y vais tout le temps tout
le temps parce que me former pour créer
ce projet est essentiel parce que si je
veux que ça fonctionne je ne peux pas
arriver comme ça tiens c'est super je
vais faire ça un provost ouais ça va
durer un an
voilà l'empreinte que je veux laisser et
voilà comment je vois je pense
demain je vous invite à réaliser vos
rêves et à ne rien lâcher pour terminer
j'aimerais citer oscar wilde et oscar
wilde disait il faut toujours viser la
lune est devant le pire des cas
l'atterrissage se fera dans les étoiles
merci beaucoup pour votre attention
[Musique]